do you have hobbies I really like to
cosplay do you like chocolate yes quite
the little alien from the nighties movie
what is his catchphrase et phone home hi
my name is Jack Wallace and I'm a
dialect coach here in Hollywood today I
am trying to discover who has the real
British accent hi I'm Hayley and I'm
from London hello my name is Bret Locke
and I'm from London hi I'm Chloe and I'm
from London
I'm gonna listen up for different things
that they may say I am absolutely going
to pull the wool over this guy's eyes
the way they say words he might find me
but I'm gonna attempt to not sound so
British maybe even their word use there
is no way that this guy is ever gonna
find me home like invisible there are
certain things that Americans tend to do
in British accents there are certain
things that are straightly insensitive
in British accents so it depends where
the fakers are from for example the word
walk or talk American speakers will
often get the right sound but shorten it
and it becomes walk and it's just
slightly off I'm worried about
and sometimes I accidentally do aand
which is like an exception to the rule
of the O's in the A's if that makes
sense
so sometimes I'm like on but it should
be and you know I'm not really nervous
about any phrases or words that I might
need a sakers can't really think of any
of it if it comes up I'll just probably
crap my pants or something sure so let's
get started
[Music]
start with you right next to me I
couldn't get you to sure come up
excellent
so what's your name my name is Bret
Locke and what do you do I'm actually a
writer so I've written several novels
and few screenplays which is why I'm
here great well I see you've got a
jacket on like me potentially English
because of that when you get to a
building and you have to enter that
building
what would you generally enter through
through through the doorway yeah yeah
excellent very good if your mother were
to ring your phone and you were to miss
it you would have to do something to
reach her what would you do call her
back
excellent yeah thank you I need to move
on no let's just go going good night
sure so what is your name I'm Chloe and
what do you do I work at BuzzFeed do you
have any favorite hobbies or anything
editing mm-hmm videos one of the things
that's happening here is we're luck good
to speak but this might be to throw me
off my game you said that you your
hobbies are editing yes going on
vacation okay yeah nice choice of word
there
again yeah exactly
there are dialectical words that we can
look out for when we're trying to suss
out where someone's from in case is a
very American word so again it could be
intentionally try this maybe after said
or might have been a slip-up and then
the way that she said holiday was pretty
emphasized but again it could just be
because I'm this judgmental person here
try to listen to how you talk so it will
remain to be seen them okay I have next
one Hayley Hayley wonderful and what do
you do
I actually act oh very nice have I seen
you in anything
do you play video games I do um I was in
life is strange before I joined you what
they had there how long have you been in
America um three years when you're in a
certain place for a certain time you may
adopt certain features from that country
for example I've been here for six years
now and my teas in the middle of words
such as water Saturday if I'm not
thinking become water Saturday and
that's just something that happens
through osmosis over time so because
you've been here a little bit longer
it's possible you might have other
features that the other two don't
and apart from video games and active do
you have hobbies I really like to
cosplay yeah do you have any favorite
costumes I'm working
on Persephone from Laurel impass and
it's based off of a webcomic
typically there's a slightly more kind
of nasal twang to some American accents
there's a little bit of overtones but
you don't necessarily get in British
sound so this sounds coming straight out
of your mouth which is great there's a
tendency to over reach it too or like in
cause play rather than cosplay the
jury's still out for now great if I
could get you to go back okay so got
some intel there but in order to get the
final results I'm gonna talk to each
person for 30 seconds final round let's
see how it goes have you ever spent any
time in the southern hemisphere
no no interesting if you were to agree
with something what would you say like
do you like chocolate yes quite I have
some suspicions about this one thank you
[Music]
okay the little alien from the nighties
movie ET what what is his catchphrase et
phone home
interesting great I was listening out to
that oh valve in her voice at the moment
is the one that switches between the two
so I was seeing which way it's lying
whether it's more towards an English
sound or an American sound if you're
injured and you have to go to the
emergency room what's the name of that
big building Hospital okay thank you so
you know that Harry Potter series thing
as you process what is the main Weasley
boy called Ron and his best friends
Harry and Hermione if you were to what a
TV show that's like SVU criminal might
what's the name of that kind of
franchise law and order one of the
things that happens in that phrase
specifically we occasionally put
something called an intrusive are in a
word when there were two valves together
law and order and it becomes often law
and order and in some British accents
but we never say they are on the end of
order she did not say they are but she
also did not add one law order so yeah I
think everybody is doing a great job
today that everyone's tried to deceive
me and they're doing different things in
different ways
Brett is very good at getting the kind
of flow of the way that he talks but
there are some sounds that sound like
they might come from down under
Chloe has been the most reluctant to
speak today and she also has some sounds
that tend towards American but then when
she's relaxed they sound a little more
English and then Haley yeah sounds very
natural and has the things kind of
flowing nicely but then there are a
couple of sounds that seem to be too
perfect almost that in real life
sometimes go away so my final decision
based on the information that I had been
given and listening for
my person who I think is from England is
close
all right good job
what are you doing anything
intentionally to throw me off yeah I was
like throwing in some Americanisms here
and there when you were consciously
thinking about your answers to me you
said things like vacation you had that
Oh in the home and phone home instead of
paying home but when you very first came
out you were like hi that it's really
hard to do a fake accent of your own
accent when he said Law & Order as soon
as he brought that up
I like noticed I was like oh no I forgot
the are at the end of law and that's
like something that I have been working
on trying to integrate it it's very hard
to talk in a fake version of your own
accent so I just kept trying to add on
like bits of American to like throw him
off the scent but it was very confused
and all over the place and I'm so bummed
that I said something at the top that
he's like caught immediately I didn't
even realize I said anything but he
caught it he's obviously very good
[Music]